today the Red Cross of Southern Nevada
honored 12 local volunteers the honorees
were recognized for their commitment to
Nationwide disaster relief Preparing
People for the unexpected and
reconnecting families 8 News now's very
own Kirsten Joyce mced the event
recipients of the awards say they just
love give they just love rather giving
back to our community
I just like to volunteer for different
organizations and I picked the Red Cross
because they respond to home flyers and
disasters and all around it's just a
great organization to volunteer with
service you can find the complete list
of honorees on our website